empecemos con una matriz de 2 x 2
la famosa matriz con entradas a d
y d
y bueno esta matriz está compuesta por
dos vectores columna este vector columna
que llamémosle el vector b 1 y este
vector columna al cual le vamos a llamar
b 2 y podemos describirlos por acá de 1
es igual al vector
y b2 pues es igual al vector de d
y bueno son dos vectores que pertenecen
a r2 y pues sería bueno graficar los
para tener una imagen visual de estos
vectores entonces vamos a poner aquí
nuestros ejes el eje vertical
y el eje horizontal y entonces nuestro
primer vector b1 digamos que es este
vector
este es uno y su coordenada horizontal
es esta que tiene el valor de a mientras
que su coordenada vertical pues está por
acá y tiene un valor de c ahora vamos
con el vector b 2 digamos que es un
vector por acá
de 2 y su coordenada horizontal pues
está por acá y es b mientras que su
coordenada vertical está por acá y es de
y en lo que nos vamos a enfocar en este
vídeo es en el paralelogramo definido
por estos dos vectores aunque hay como
son podemos pensar que son vectores de
posición o sea que aquí nos definen dos
puntitos justo el punto hace y bb y
vamos a considerar también el punto cero
cero para que ella tengamos tres puntos
del paralelogramo y pues ya que tenemos
los tres puntos del paralelogramo
tenemos ya muy bien definido al
paralelogramo no ya tenemos dos lados
estos dos lados que no son paralelos
entonces los otros dos lados del
paralelo gramo tienen que ser paralelos
a estos así es que otro lado de este
paralelogramo se tiene que ver más o
menos
así como paralelo a este lado y el otro
lado más o menos así y algo que nos
interesa mucho que vamos a ver en este
vídeo es el área de este paralelogramo
ok
para logramos
gramos
ahora los parales logramos ya sabemos
muy bien cómo sacar su área
digamos cualquier paralelogramo
este es un paralelogramo un poco chueco
pero su área se saca de la misma forma
entonces el área de este paralelogramo
nosotros sabemos que es igual a la base
esta es la base base por la altura del
paralelo gramo y para sacar la altura de
un paralelogramo lo que hacemos es sacar
aquí algo perpendicular a la base y a
este esta cosa de aquí le llamamos la
altura y el área de este paralelogramo
es simplemente base por altura entonces
cuál va a ser el área de este
paralelogramo pues igual va a ser
simplemente el área va a ser igual a la
base por la altura aunque hay pero aquí
pues podemos sustituir este base y esta
altura por los términos correspondientes
porque aquí tenemos saber 192 no
entonces este área va a ser igual a la
base
en este caso es este vector de aquí
entonces todo esto de aquí
tenemos que sacar cuál es la longitud de
este vector y esa es la base entonces
aquí nosotros sabemos que la base es
igual a la longitud del vector b 1
y tenemos que multiplicar la por la
altura pero la altura está un poco más
complicada porque aquí tenemos que sacar
una recta perpendicular
a este vector que pase por el punto por
este puntito que es representado por b 2
que esta recta tiene que ser ortogonal a
b 2 y después tenemos que sacar la
longitud de este segmento y como le
vamos a hacer para hacer eso como vamos
a encontrar a esta h pues algo que
podemos hacer es tratar de encontrar
este vector destructor de aquí por qué
pues porque si encontramos este vector y
lo encontramos en términos que ya
conozcamos sociedad en términos de b1 y
b2 entonces podemos hacer el teorema de
pitágoras y encontrar a h a través de
estos dos vectores ok porque como este
es un ángulo recto entonces la longitud
de este vector al cuadrado más h al
cuadrado es igual a la norma del vector
2 la longitud de este vector al cuadrado
y entonces así podemos encontrar h ok
pero cómo le hacemos para encontrar este
vector de aquí bueno pues resulta que
este vector de aquí es la proyección del
vector de 2 sobre la línea generada por
el vector b 1 aunque yo creo que tenemos
que empezar por generar la línea así es
que digamos que él
y
generaba
n
x
el rector héctor de uno que es lo que
hacemos para generar a él pues tomamos
el vector de uno y tomamos todos los
puntos que se pueden representar como
una escalar veces ese vector ok estamos
tomando todos los múltiplos del vector b
1 o sea que con eso vamos a generar este
instructor este vector también por acá
aquí todos estos puntos se pueden poner
como una escala de 6 b 1 y lo mismo para
acá
ok entonces esta es la línea del esta es
el y entonces este vector de acá
este vector de acá es la proyección
pero llegué
sión
sobre la línea l de el vector de 2
de hecho a lo largo de este vídeo en
lugar escribir toda la palabra
proyección simplemente vamos a poner
proyección sobre la línea l1 la cual es
generada por el vector de uno de el
vector de dos ok bueno y como estamos
tan seguros de que en realidad este
vector es la proyección de ver dos sobre
la línea l pues tal vez digo no podemos
demostrarlo ahorita eso lo vimos hace
muchísimos vídeos pero ahí está en algún
lugar de la página pero tal vez esto te
recuerde un poco que tenemos aquí
nuestra recta tenemos aquí nuestro
objeto y podemos pensar en que el sol
está en algún punto muy lejano
perpendicular a esta línea ok y entonces
manda a sus rayos de luz por aquí
y este vector de acá es la sombra que
proyecta este vector bueno creo que
sería mejor borrar nuestros rayos de luz
ok entonces ya que tenemos aquí todos
los elementos ya podemos calcular cuánto
vale h
porque por el teorema de pitágoras como
aquí tenemos un ángulo recto entonces
esto es un cateto este es otro cateto y
esta es la hipotenusa entonces podemos
usar el teorema de pitágoras que nos
dice que la longitud de este lado que es
h simplemente al cuadrado más
la longitud de este otro vector que es
la proyección sobre l del vector de 2
longitud se mide con la norma
de proyección sobre el del vector de 2
la norma de este vector al cuadrado que
es este cateto al cuadrado eso estas dos
cantidades son iguales a la longitud de
este otro vector que es la hipotenusa
que es el vector b2 b2 su longitud al
cuadrado ok esto es simplemente el
teorema de pitágoras no hay nada extraño
por aquí si no te suena el teorema de
pitágoras seguro puedes encontrarlo en
algún vídeo en la página esto es
simplemente el
teorema
d
pitágoras pitágoras aunque hay aquí está
fórmula nunca la terminamos aquí
estévez es simplemente la norma del
vector b 1 como veíamos por acá y aquí
nos falta ponerle una h y entonces
nosotros queremos encontrar h pero pues
empecemos por encontrar h cuadrada ok
entonces podemos despejar y lo que nos
queda es que h al cuadrado es igual a la
norma del vector b 2 al cuadrado pero la
norma de un vector al cuadrado es igual
a tomar el vector y hacerle producto
punto consigo mismo
y por qué porque si este es el vector
por ejemplo x cuando haces el producto
punto de xy producto punto equis y lo
que te queda es x cuadrada más re
cuadrada y eso es el cuadrado de la
norma del vector b 2 entonces esta norma
del vector b 2 al cuadrado la podemos
escribir como b 2 producto punto b 2 y
luego tenemos que restarle
la norma de la proyección sobre la recta
l del vector b 2 pero también hace un
montón de vídeos vimos una forma para
encontrar esto
la proyección sobre la recta l del
vector de 2 esto lo que vimos hace un
montón de vídeos es que es igual a b 2
que este producto punto b 1 que es el
generador de la recta sobre la cual se
estamos proyectando que es la recta l
entre una especie de la norma del vector
generador que es b 1 producto punto b 1
y algo que hay que notar aquí es que una
vez que hacemos el producto punto entre
dos vectores eso es igual a un número un
número real aunque entonces todo esto de
aquí es simplemente un número de hecho
hasta lo podemos ver como un escalar
entonces multiplicamos a este escalar
por el vector que genera a la recta l
que en este caso es b uno de uno ok
entonces tenemos aquí a de uno y lo
multiplicamos por un escalar el escalar
apropiado que hace que nos quede un
vector sobre esta misma recta l pero que
sea justo la proyección de nuestro
vector b 2 sobre la recta l y es justo
este el escalar que hace que eso suceda
entonces aquí lo que tenemos que poner
como pasamos la norma de la proyección
sobre l del vector
b 2 al cuadrado del otro lado del igual
los resta más que entonces tenemos que
poner aquí la norma de este vector
de dos productos punto de uno
/ v 1 producto punto b 1
y luego este es una escala que está
multiplicando al vector b 1
aunque y tenemos que elevar esa norma al
cuadrado
ok y esta norma como se saca al igual
que como lo vimos aquí la norma de un
vector al cuadrado es simplemente el
producto punto del vector consigo mismo
aunque entonces aquí h cuadrada es igual
déjame pongo este con el mismo color
de dos productos punto de dos que es la
norma del vector de 2 - y aquí tenemos
el escalar de dos producto punto de uno
/ v 1 producto punto b 1
por el vector b1 que todo esto es un
vector pero esta es su parte escalar y
este es el vector vector producto punto
otra vez el escalar de dos productos
punto b 1 / b 1 producto punto b 1
por el vector b1 ok entonces vamos a
tener que seguir reescribiendo esto h 2
es igual de 2 producto punto b 2 ahora
nosotros sabemos que el producto punto
entre dos vectores es asociativo con
respecto a los escalares
si eso es equivalente a decir que el
producto punto saca escalares que
entonces aquí tenemos menos este escalar
que es de 2 producto punto de 1
/ v 1 producto punto b 1
por el otro escalar o sea v2 producto
punto de 1 / v 1 producto punto b 1
que ella sé que son el mismo y podría
tal vez aquí nada más ponerle el
cuadrado pero creo que los vamos a
necesitar escritos con todas sus letras
y entonces este es una escala que está
multiplicando a este producto punto
entre estos dos vectores o sea que está
multiplicando a b1 producto punto b 1 y
entonces podemos decir que éste se
cancela con este y entonces ya nada más
nos quedan estos números pueden volver a
escribir por acá
h al cuadrado es igual
de dos productos punto b 2 no se nos
olvide de 2 producto punto de 2 - aquí
tenemos de 2 producto punto b 1 2 veces
o sea de dos productos punto b 1
al cuadrado entre uno solo de estos de
v1 producto punto b uno no de un
producto punto de uno aunque entonces
esto es h al cuadrado pero nosotros
queríamos nada más
h cierto
a ver aquí en nuestra fórmula para el
área de este paralelogramo nosotros
sabemos que tenemos aquí que el área es
igual a estévez que es simplemente la
norma del vector de uno que es el que
genera la línea l
aquí tenemos por aquí algunos b 1 por h
no h al cuadrado si quisiéramos h aquí
podríamos simplemente sacar raíz
cuadrada de los dos lados y tendríamos h
igual a la raíz de esta resta pero todo
se complicaría muchísimo más entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es primero encontrar
el área al cuadrado que es simplemente
esta norma de un vector al cuadrado por
h al cuadrado la cual ya la tenemos por
acá y después sacarle la raíz cuadrada
al área al cuadrado
ok entonces por aquí tenemos que el área
al cuadrado es igual teníamos por ahí
que era la norma del vector b 1
al cuadrado por h al cuadrado de h al
cuadrado
y hay que hacer hincapié en que esta
cantidad ya la tenemos es esta de acá
que son estos productos puntos entre
vectores que ya conocemos así es que el
área al cuadrado es igual a b1 producto
punto b 1
de un producto punto de uno porque eso
es igual a la norma del vector al
cuadrado por b 2 producto punto de 2
menos de 2 producto punto b 1 al
cuadrado
/ v 1 producto punto b 1
pero aquí ya no nos queda espacio
entonces vamos a pasarnos para que
tenemos que el área al cuadrado es igual
a todo esto de aquí vamos a distribuir
el paréntesis entonces de 1 producto
punto b 1 que es un número real por b 2
producto punto b2b 1 producto punto b 1
x
de dos productos punto de dos
y aquí pues tenemos que es de 1 producto
punto b 1 por de 2 producto punto b 1 al
cuadrado / b 1 producto punto b 1
entonces como son números tal cual éste
se va a cancelar con este y entonces nos
queda nada más este de aquí que por
cierto se está restando entonces aquí
nos quedan menos de dos productos punto
de uno
al cuadrado y yo creo que es tiempo de
recordar quiénes son los vectores b2 b1
aquí tenemos que el vector de 1 es el
vector hacer
y el vector de 2 es el vector b de
entonces ya vamos a llegar a la parte en
la que sustituimos los valores de los
vectores b1 y b2
que hay aquí tenemos que tener en mente
todo el tiempo a partir de este momento
que ve uno es igual al vector
y b2 es igual al vector de d
aunque entonces nosotros tenemos que el
área al cuadrado de nuestro
paralelogramo es igual a b1 producto
punto b 1 ok entonces tenemos aquí b 1
que es hace producto punto hace saber
con escribirlo porque
producto punto
y como se saque el producto punto pues
esto es simplemente este por este que es
cuadrada más este por este que es
cuadrada ok y así igual vamos a hacer
para el resto de estos productos puntos
entonces yo creo que mejor vamos a
borrarlo y ponerlo directamente
aunque entonces de un producto punto b 1
es cuadrada +
se cuadrada y esto lo tenemos que
multiplicar por b 2 producto punto b2 b2
producto punto b 2 es simplemente de
cuadrada porque es b por b de cuadrada
más
depor de que es de cuadrada de cuadrada
y después tenemos que restarle de dos
productos punto v 1 al cuadrado
entonces tenemos que restar de dos
productos punto b 1
a por b
por ver más
de porsche o sea se por d al cuadrado
aunque entonces nosotros queremos
desarrollar esto así es que tenemos que
el área al cuadrado de nuestro
paralelogramo
a cuadrada por de cuadrada a cuadrada
por be cuadrada más cuadrada por de
cuadrada a cuadrada por be cuadrada
más cuadrada por be cuadrada se cuadrada
por be cuadrada más
se cuadrada por de cuadrada se cuadrada
por de cuadrada y ahora menos lo que nos
quede desarrollando este binomio al
cuadro y de eso lo que nos queda es a
por b al cuadrado o sea a cuadrada de
cuadrada y después tenemos que
multiplicar éste por éste por un 2 o sea
que nos queda más dos por a b c de más
el otro término al cuadrado osea cede al
cuadrado se cuadrada de cuadrada y
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
distribuir este menos a lo largo del
paréntesis entonces vamos a copiar esto
tal cual aquí
a cuadrada de cuadrada más cuadrada de
cuadrada más cuadrada de cuadrada más
se cuadrada de cuadrada
y ahora vamos a distribuir este signo
menos dentro del paréntesis y de eso lo
que nos queda es menos a cuadrada de
cuadrada menos a cuadrada de cuadrada
menos 2
abc de 2 a b c d
y menos se cuadrada de cuadrada
pero ya que tenemos aquí los términos
con sus signos menos podemos ver que se
van a cancelar un montón de ellos no yo
por ejemplo aquí tenemos a cuadrada de
cuadrada y aquí tenemos menos a cuadrada
b cuadrado entonces estos dos se
cancelan y aquí tenemos se cuadrada de
cuadrada y por aquí también lo tenemos
entonces se cancelen y finalmente nos
queda a cuadrada que es en nuestro área
al cuadrado igual a cuadrada de cuadrada
más cuadrada de cuadrada menos 2 a b c d
entonces tú qué opinas te suena familiar
esta expresión o todavía no
bueno te voy a dar una pista vamos a
escoger otras variables nada más para
hacer este cálculo o sea de aquí ya
podríamos simplificar esta expresión
todavía otro paso
vamos a usar estas variables x y xi x va
a ser igual a por de y va a ser igual a
por qué entonces si escribimos esta
expresión utilizando estas variables xy
ya que las estoy dando como pista
entonces esto es igual
a por de que es igual a x x al cuadrado
más se por b que es y al cuadrado al
cuadrado y aquí tenemos menos 2 x y aquí
tenemos otra vez
y tenemos b&c o sea que tenemos equis
porque entonces qué tal ya sabes qué es
lo que traigo en mente bueno seguramente
te acuerdas de que esto es el desarrollo
de un binomio al cuadrado como el que
teníamos aquí
no entonces esto de aquí es exactamente
igual
x más al cuadrado
pero no lo podemos dejar en términos de
xy ya tenemos que regresar esto a
términos de a de vc y ponemos aquí x
iguala a d entonces tenemos que esto es
igual a x de más ya que es igual a c b
y tenemos nuestro binomio al cuadrado ok
entonces el área de nuestro
paralelogramo es igual a de más cb al
cuadrado si no te suena conocido esto
que hicimos para que busquen en la
página los vídeos del binomio al
cuadrado pero a ver espero no haberte
confundido
esta cosa de aquí todo esto es
exactamente igual a esta cosa de acá que
no hay necesidad de poner las xy leyes
sólo las puse porque creo que puede
ayudar a que uno visualice bien qué es
lo que tenemos aquí pero tal cual esta
cosa de aquí es exactamente igual a esta
cosa de aquí acabo de notar que he hecho
un error aquí aquí yo lo que puse fue x
+ d pero esto no es así cierto porque
aquí lo que tenemos es menos dos por xy
así es que aquí en lugar de que sea x
nadie lo que tenemos es un x menos d
x menos de ok aquí también tenemos a de
menos veces que si aquí tuviéramos unas
2 x llevo aquí tuviéramos un +2 a dsb
entonces sí tendríamos a de más veces
pero aquí lo que tenemos es un menos así
es que si nos queda por acá el menos
bueno tenía que cometer un error de
cuentas eventualmente no
entonces saber aquí el área de nuestro
paralelogramo elevada al cuadrado es
igual a de menos se ve elevado al
cuadrado y eso no suena muy familiar no
sobre todo en esta sección de vídeos
esto tiene que saltarnos a la vista por
qué pues porque esto de aquí a ver vamos
a regresar nos para allá para recordar
cuál es nuestra matriz original
aquí nosotros empezamos con una matriz
que es la matriz que tiene x entradas a
b c d y que además es tal que sus
vectores columna
son vectores estos vectores columna son
los vectores que forman un paralelogramo
del cual nos estamos preguntando cuál es
su variedad y cuál es el determinante de
esta matriz a pues es el mismo valor de
siempre que es a por de menos b por c
ahora si ya les suena algo
entonces esto de aquí es igual a el
determinante de la matriz a y lo estamos
elevando al cuadrado
o sea este es el determinante de a de c
b y eso está súper bonito
super elegante tenemos que el área el
área de nuestro paralelogramo
paralelogramo que acabamos de una matriz
a teníamos allí en nuestra matriz y
sacábamos los vectores columna y estos
vectores formaban los lados del paralelo
gramo bueno el chiste es que el área al
cuadrado de ese paralelogramo es igual
al determinante de la matriz de la cual
sacamos los vectores que determinan los
lados del paralelo gramo al cuadrado
aunque entonces pueden sacar raíz
cuadrada de los dos lados y lo que queda
es que simplemente el área
del paralelogramo es igual a el valor
absoluto del determinante de la matriz
de la cual sacamos los lados y ahí es
muy importante es todo el valor absoluto
pero bueno el chiste es que este es un
resultado súper elegante super conciso
está aquí escrito en esta ecuación y eso
es algo increíble tomando en cuenta la
cantidad de cálculos que tuvimos que
hacer
aunque tenemos aquí a la matriz cuyos
vectores columna determinan los lados lo
que nos interesa es este área de aquí
y lo que acabamos de ver es que esta
área del paralelogramo es igual vamos a
escribirlo por aquí el área del
paralelogramo es igual a el valor
absoluto del determinante de la matriz a
entonces vamos por partes porque es
súper importante esto el valor absoluto
del determinante de a porque como hemos
visto los determinantes pueden ser
negativos y el área de un paralelogramo
siempre es positiva por un lado y por el
otro si por ejemplo cambiamos estos dos
vectores del lugar
estos dos vectores columna nosotros
sabemos por unos vídeos que hemos visto
últimamente que eso lo que hace es que
cambia el signo del determinante sin
embargo si por ejemplo este vector lo
cambiamos de este lado y se convierte en
este vector y lo mismo este vector lo
ponemos de este lado entonces pues el
paralelogramo que van a formar van a ser
el mismo y por lo tanto el área va a ser
la misma sin embargo ahora el
determinante va a tener un signo menos
por ahí
con el valor absoluto estamos haciendo
que sean exactamente iguales estas dos
cantidades además de tomar en cuenta eso
de que el área siempre es un valor
positivo en fin a mí me parece que este
resultado es precioso y es muy
importante que lo veamos porque
originalmente el determinante
considerábamos que era una cantidad muy
importante porque salía allí de la nada
de hecho lo definimos así como de la
nada haciendo algunos cálculos tratando
de invertir algunas matrices y el
determinante como hemos visto es súper
importante porque gracias a él podemos
determinar si una matriz es invertible o
no si el determinante es igual a cero
entonces la matriz no es invertible y si
el determinante es distinto de cero eso
nosotros sabemos que podemos invertir
esa matriz pero aquí encontramos que
tiene otra aplicación súper bonita o sea
tal cual si tenemos un paralelogramo y
tomamos los vectores que representan los
lados del paralelo gramo formando una
matriz con él
donde cada lado del paralelogramo sea un
vector columna y le sacamos el
determinante a esa matriz obtenemos
súper fácilmente el área de ese
paralelogramo sin tener que hacer
rotaciones ni circo maroma y teatro
simplemente hacemos el cálculo del
determinante de la matriz y listo